hey guys this is des the founder take
care and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the second to the last
episode of Breaking Bad Emer yes Granite
State yeah which is its season 5 episode
15 of the penultimate episode yes well
before we get into review that's a
congratulations to break a man they just
won the Emmy and a gun for vet well the
perks 914 Skylar as best supporting
actress and more importantly the series
itself won its first emmy for best
dramatic series that's big and I mean
his mad men had pretty much dominated
that category for several years in a row
yeah and then homeland had walked home
and one last year so well let's get into
this episode this you know this
episode's a lot of setup stuff yes sir
for next week's series finale not season
finale series finale right I mean some
some good scenes in this I you know I
mean you know to start I'm interesting
seeing you know we're finally getting to
know where Walter you know how he ended
up where he ended up you know a lot of
kind of bouncing around this episode
again it was a lot of setup I don't mind
some of the earlier episodes this season
were set up a nose like okay why are we
still setting up but this episode makes
more sense because it is the episode
before the finale you kind of need some
setup to get everything going for the
finale oh yeah now we see how how Walter
ended up in New hamburger you know he
you know took the like whatever the new
identity right up with Saul you know
Robert Forrester is some of you guys
know his famous actor he plays like kind
of the guy that that takes care of
whoever they need the new ideas or and
and Walters up in that cabin and you
kind of see how sad his life has become
he's a guy ten thousand dollars to play
cards for an hour a bad time you know
thousand-odd for an hour cards yeah it's
basically showing that look he has all
this money but it's useless to him it's
worthless to him I mean he hasn't his
family he's not with his family his
family hates him he can't even talk to
anyone has been friends he can't go
outside like he's basically he's given
his whole he's sacrificed all that and
done a lot of terrible things
then I who knows if he actually regrets
or not it so hard to tell if he's even
telling the truth if you speaking the
truth it's just he's gotten so good
because so that awesome scene last
weekly before were Walter was you know
rehearsing we saw him pre Heisenberg
Ariz rehearsing what he's gonna say this
guy I'm rehearsing alive but now they
just flow off of his tongue so it's hard
to talk to even tell the truth yeah but
I mean I felt like the phone call that
he made to Walton Jr what he was family
he loves his kids yeah yeah and and he's
realized wow like I did all this stuff
in it didn't matter right it doesn't
matter you know before when he was had
no money and he was struggling and we
see had his family his freedom all these
things and now he's found that his money
is useless nobody wants and I mean
that's that's the sad thing is that's
all he has left I mean the one thing
that he's giving all offering Walt Jr is
as much like sorry that's all I have and
well you're just like you want to give
us money he's like I don't want that
crap yeah I mean he wants a father he
wants the family that he thought he had
he won I doesn't he wants his dad not to
be a murderer penned rookie being yeah
you know he still thinks that he killed
hey uncle Hank even though he did was I
know kind of still talking focusing kind
of on the end right now but still i'ma
just to go off that I mean his ego I
mean that just drives him I'm in the end
you see that he's watching the whole
thing about you know grey matters and
the corporation that he started and he
didn't get his cut of that
billion-dollar kind of we told Jesse
last he'll it's a billion-dollar company
on all that and she's his ego as soon as
they said you know that that name you
know we came up with that name you could
just see his like clench and he's just
like it right there you know he's not
think about his family no he's gonna go
back to get what's his to get his drug
money to out he might even go after grey
matter i don't know what is gonna do but
he's gonna go he's gonna get back what's
his yeah and also you hear that last
part where she's like well the walter
white is is gone the line the guy the
sweet nice guy that we know yeah there's
only heisenberg left right so he's like
he kind of took that as you're right
yeah you know I have nothing my family
doesn't love me anymore I'm there is
only Eisenberg left right so yeah
we've already seen those flash forwards
and so I am assuming in the series
finale he's taking that machine gun and
trying to kill anyone who's ever gonna
get stung yeah and then I thought we had
some great moments this week to with a
you know Jesse and Todd especially Todd
especially thought this is gothic I
don't call it Todd centric episode me a
lot Todd what is what Todd well I seem
to Todd this episode well yeah I mean we
kind of see like why he's still wanting
to I mean we kind of knew that before
but even more so why he still wants to
keep cooking I mean they have all this
money now but he wants to impress this
lady lady a girl who I'm sorry I don't
get it yeah annoys me all the time she's
so paranoid even still and and he just
wants to impress her and he you know he
even goes and scares a Skylar yes he's
afraid that that she's gonna talk about
Lydia she don't really know much about
or you just she know she shines yeah she
has no idea what context like what she
does I mean now we don't even really
know what I mean we know she makes she
sets up contact she's the go to middle
name middle man yeah but I mean no one
would never really seen like the full
extent of everything that she does so
yeah I mean she's she's safe and he's
just trying to press her with the oh and
now the cooks 92% cuz we got jelly I
mean that's the whole reason why I jest
he's still alive and well Jesse's a
great escape yeah he uh he escaped and
for like I don't know how many seconds
almost 30 seconds yeah got to the fence
with a barbed wire and he couldn't make
it over and they're all there and he was
just like I'm done with this just kill
me but they went kill his girl yeah
Todd's cold I was wrong I mean Todd's
akola mofo man cuz like the hill and
killing kids which they reveal or not
they reveal to us but they revealed to
his I guess is I assumed that his uncle
and his rest his family and that whole
crew knew he did that well they kind of
looked at him like yeah they didn't know
they did that right so
and and and then killing Andrea so what
I'm really curious about because we've
seen future Walter we know he's got the
gun who's got the beer the he's back on
chemo it seems like you know he's for
his cancer but we wonder like what's
Jesse gonna be like I'm assuming it's
been several months got a full deer that
Walter yeah full head of hair i'm
guessing it's been five six months maybe
i'm just getting skinny now raised
wedding we follow yeah he's got his hair
back he's uh she wonder like what
Jesse's gonna look like six months from
now what's Todd doing you know six
months from you know when we saw so i'll
be curious that's finale i think is
gonna be it's gonna be exciting i hope
it's uh i don't usually do that big gun
i mean we had to go back to that i think
is gonna be a good sign question is
who's he going to use that big gun i'm
obviously we know that those you know
Nazi guys obviously but you know is
jesse gonna get caught in the crossfire
is gonna free Jesse because we thought
he was gonna like we thought maybe his
family would be in trouble but obviously
they're fine and I don't think todd has
he already talked to scholar he has no
reason to go back after her again so
yeah I mean we know what's what's he
going I don't think it's gonna be a
heroic fate for Walter White i think you
know I I think he's gonna die I think
he's gonna die in a blaze of blaze of
bullets yeah and I the question is you
know how many people is he gonna kill
and who is he targeting and who does he
actually get to and is he gonna let's
say if Jesse come across his path is
gonna let Jesse liver not it might be at
the point we'd be like screw it it was
Jesse gonna do yeah jesse has a gun if
he has good this one is Jesse gonna take
down wall right who knows and how to
happen what happens to his family right
right cuz family still under the Skylar
still under indictment and all this
stuff maybe Walt white and turns himself
in I don't know yeah that's gonna be
good you know as it usually moved for
him to alert the cops to his position
you know I don't that was to throw them
off his trail like maybe he's playing on
leaving we know he's leaving he's coming
back maybe he's like okay now look for
him in New Hampshire and then he
I don't know it's interesting I pretty
good we good finale the two most
effective scenes well there's a few
effective scenes only one obviously
Andrew getting killed and jesse pinkman
going in realizing you know they can
still do more to him hurt him and then
also just a phone call total Walt Jr
from wall yeah those are great because I
think that's kind of like the last the
last bit of hope he had was kind of like
okay if I can at least send money to my
family yeah you know leave this money
but now it's it's too late yeah it's
it's over four and then here that
interview on TV is cholesterol he's he's
done she's he's going all out alright
guys so what do you guys think of the
episode and also what do you think it's
gonna happen in the series finale who's
gonna live who's gonna die is Walt gonna
die is gonna go to jail is Jesse gonna
live he's gonna die was gently gonna
kill Walt yeah he's won't gonna kill
Jesse he's dying who's done is living
and why and what's gonna happen to meth
Damon Todd like Oh Matt Damon do you
know he's done some pretty despicable
things I mean very cold-hearted like is
he gonna get his or I don't know Todd's
we looks like sometimes I know he's a
psychopath I know he's crazy I know he's
me but like he was kind of nice about
Skylar because Lydia I think Lydia
wanted I think him to kill Skylar cuz
Lydia kept saying you know like you know
hey like I'd rather be assured that
she's not gonna say anything and he's
like well I think I scared I think
she'll be she won't say anything but
yeah Todd's crazy yeah nose nose in it
he's crazy all right guys you post your
comments below on our website thing
CARICOM or on our youtube channel at
think hero pro make sure you subscribe
you also can find us on twitter and chat
with this i'm at think era I'm at a
Griffin de and we have saw the facebook
page that's a facebook.com slash think
hero fans
you